this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody welcome to Juma
in the sabi sands in South Africa where
we have found a beautiful European Rolla
perched beautifully on the end or the
top of a termite mound it's looking such
nice colors today
very fresh / image it seems some
beautiful blues really really
interesting to see it is a wonderful 33
or 34 degrees Fahrenheit not 34 degrees
cells is 94 degrees Fahrenheit and
probably about 200 percent humidity it
is unbelievably sticky this afternoon as
the bird is now opened its beak to do
some gala fluttering to cool itself down
no doubt in anticipation for some
termites air leads to be coming out of
the termite mound so it can pick up some
bulk and with its new plumage in
readiness for migrating a back up to
sort of Eastern Central Europe good
afternoon everybody my name is Steve
joined by beak on camera don't forget we
are interactive would love to hear from
you
hashtags for alar will throw your
questions in a new youtube chest tube
don't forget the all-important @fc
should we have another look at this bird
it's not often we get to see the
European rollouts sitting like that on
the end of a term amount normally we
find these birds perched on the top of a
dead tree they are insect eaters and the
European roller is silent in Africa Oh
off it's gone and I'll forego it's
beautiful it is a very very sticky this
afternoon everybody and we headed to
lose last knots of rain that came down
and covered the landscape
wiping the carpets or the ground wiping
the ground fresh and clean for any new
tracks so we're gonna see what we can
find this afternoon I would love to see
if we can find shadaloo of course with
her Cubs but it might be a little bit
too early in the afternoon but anyway
we're gonna go around and see what
tracks they might be heading into that
direction because it wouldn't it be
wonderful I had some fresh tracks of her
yesterday but after this rain or the old
tracks are gone and all that will be
there are fresh activity so maybe she's
come in and out again and go and have a
look let's go never look who do big sort
of loop around that block and see what
has happened
there's been no reports of hookah mori
leaving the property I have a feeling
he's on a kill somewhere in Sylar
property we just haven't really found
him so that could be the chance or
opportunity for this afternoon follow up
on hookah mori follow up on shadaloo and
see if we can find any who could you
lose wouldn't that be awesome and all of
you back home are sort of choking at the
bit to see some new leopard cubs and
well I hope we can provide them for you
but the rains that we had came down with
enormous lightning storms seemingly
hitting the roof around where ours look
for our sleeping last night woke me up
at about Hoppus - Wow it was frightening
I don't normally get it I don't only get
afraid of lightning but it honestly felt
like the lightning bolts were hitting
the building so I just unplugged
everything that I had and climbed up to
my bed didn't I didn't well I didn't die
I'm here but it is added to an enormous
amount of humidity that is a thick fog
blanket of moisture in the air well
miss Nina I can hear you there that's
the first I can hear you go on we go and
a Czech sort of our southwestern section
of the of the property to see what has
been coming and going
some nice elephant tracks in the road
it's a good day for Elly's we go
straight down this road this is Zoe's
we've got our initial tracks of shadaloo
and her Cubs getting straight down
towards where they are potentially
Denning those of you who aren't sure
it's been going on sure dude who piers
has come back onto Juma with her two
cubs I haven't seen them yet but we did
see her yesterday morning so I'm making
it my mission to try and show them to
you
I'm sorry I actually have no idea we
don't keep our own records so it's hard
to say I know that last week we probably
got about 72 months now that's one of
the landowners told me he'd measured it
on his property up in Beaufort suck and
last night it came down I mean you can
see the road in front of us has been
washed enormous amounts of erosion has
happened
the erosion for those of you who are not
sure what that means is the movement of
sediment from one place to another so
erosion is all of this movement of the
road sort of sediment and a lot of it
coming off from the side of the roads as
well in something called sheet erosion
which is a really big problem due to
overgrazing so too many animals in an
area losing ground cover leads to sheet
erosion which eventually leads to very
very unmanageable areas when the sheets
erosion turns into gully Donga and
erosion that then becomes almost
impossible to fix without serious
management intervention so the nice slow
pattering rain that soaks in to the
ground is always the best well it seems
like Sydney who spent a lot of time this
morning trying to find the lions has
managed to relocate on them again this
afternoon
to the border between juma Game Reserve
and the buffers woke a very very good
afternoon and most of all welcome to
this particular sighting I am travelling
with sense of who is my camera operator
this afternoon and for in case if you
need our attention we are highly
available you can follow us on twitter
hashtag sephora live you can also follow
us on youtube chat stream so I just want
to count because this morning it was
very difficult for me to count them look
at that this is an amazing experience 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 so let me just
repeat that just to make sure 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11
yes the 11 at the moment is quite a very
big pride and this is the pride we
normally see as a result of the presence
of buffalos but unfortunately I haven't
seen the buffaloes for quite a while the
last time I have seen the buffalos it
was just the tracks and that was about
three days ago if not four days ago
somewhere around the same depeche area
they were some fresh tracks of buffalos
today we saw the mating youngest
unco Huma female with one of their focus
so you can see that now it's time for
them to rest but it's difficult at the
moment for me to judge where they're
gonna go for a drink afterwards because
here we are it's not very far away from
Sydney stem it's just about few minutes
away and the gallic open is on a
distance unless they've got a mission of
going to do some hunt much more towards
the Calico pain area i will be here for
the whole day to try and see what their
intentions that what their intentions
are by looking at the stomach i can tell
that they are not very hungry
but lions are so very opportunistic
while we're walking down to the water
holes they can show us some of their
hunting skills
Paula I have seen a white lie on before
not once not twice the white lions they
are completely different from what we
are seeing now in terms of the color and
what causes the white lions is a
phenomenon called leucism lu system is
whereby the melanistic pigment is not
very there and as a result the color of
the body turns white which is not nice
for a wild animal because when it comes
to hunting they can easily get spotted
so mostly the white lions do depend on
these ones when they are going out for
hunting
Joan I am not seeing the lioness you are
fearing to if you can just repeat that
but what I can promise you is that there
is quite a lot of Fighting's amongst the
big cats such as the lions and leopards
so their Fighting's can be so very much
vicious they do get injured sometimes
during the fighting for food and
sometimes when fighting the other
females who are trying to enter into
their territories they can be very much
protective to not only the males are
protective so by these territorial
animals females as well they do fight
against other animals of the same sex so
it's time now for some of them to groom
themselves you can see we got this one
in front and the other one in the back
also lifting up his leg there so this is
very normal
Lions they do spend much of the time
just grooming trying to get rid of the
parasites and also trying to take off
some of the debris or the dead hairs
from the body
so you can see that this area is so very
much quiet they are not making any noise
so sometimes if the wind is from their
favor is very easy for a prey animal to
bump onto them so what I like about the
Lions is when they wake up afterwards
you will see maybe that is gonna happen
while we are still here
the normally go and isolate themselves
from the group and start defecating and
urinating so they go just to defecate
when they wake up all the time and after
that is when you see them starting to do
like this as they will go and do some
stretching you see them even holding
branches from the trees like this when
they are doing some stretching when they
are now becoming active preparing in
order to walk long distances are going
for hunting activities
oh look at that poor so you can see this
is what we see on the ground suggests
that it's not showing as the underneath
pass nicely so this is how the domestic
cat as well do clean themselves so they
lick the front legs and clean the face
you can see that other one is now busy
doing some cleaning normally they do
like this early in the mornings now I
want us to see what Steve is looking for
while I'm still waiting to see if these
lions are going to entertain us more
this afternoon hello everyone we've
stopped the term amount that was
flourishing with birds a moment ago and
now they've all gone all of our surface
and swallows are flying and bombing this
some there's still a few coming around
bombing this termite mound that probably
had some fly termites elates coming out
as the European roller was doing before
you get sort of bursts of energy or
bursts of individuals coming out off to
the rain that's been a lot of
reproductives will come out when the
ground is nice and soft and then they
can go and do the new colonies but the
birds take huge advantage of it we had
probably 50 odd Birds a moment ago just
sort of dive-bombing this term up Mount
but you get moments of lots of LEDs
coming out and then obviously they start
dying down as in numbers dwindle anyway
it'll continue on
it was a lot of birds were all
drongos as well as black headed Orioles
all going absolutely crazy for the
termites although we couldn't actually
even see any but the birds were showing
us that's definitely something was going
on
okay so we're still carrying on down
this road the ground is very nice for
tracking on this roads particularly
because it's nice and soft cat lady we
work all day every day we never stop and
never have a breather don't eat lunch
breakfast or dinner we're just
constantly working I'm joking
well we present in the morning in the
afternoon so that's six hours but half
an hour either side of that for
preparation on the vehicle and then
there's always different reviews on a
Friday these days we're doing a 1/2 an
hour to an hour review on the week but
when there's TV shows there's a lot more
extra effort that goes in for example
the ABC there's an extra hour or so each
day for that for the show and then
there's also an extra hour the next day
for a review there's the morning meeting
every morning which takes up between 10
and par for 10 minutes in half an hour
there's also vehicle maintenance on
Wednesdays at Purdue cleaning and that
can take anywhere from 20 minutes to an
hour as well and then obviously as the
presenters the guards we are constantly
learning constantly refreshing our
brains and learning new techniques and
strategies and information so as to
impart it on you lovely people back home
so we should never stop working but we
need time in the day to reflect on
ourselves we exercise well most of us do
get some exercise in we definitely have
to make time for eating and well
socializing as well in the evening of
course there's just a little bit of
sitting around and chatting I wouldn't
call that work but we live here so we're
constantly pretty much on call if that
makes any sense it's not like people who
can have an an answer 5 then they go
home then they got free to themselves
there could be anything going on in an
evening but invariably most evenings are
our own and most of the time during the
day is our own time as well but that is
not always the case that answers your
question
but in the guarding industry you guide
all the time you're constantly busy Zen
you want to know where this is being
filmed while we are in jhummer in the
sabi sands which is on the north eastern
side of South Africa between Mozambique
and well six hours from Johannesburg six
and half hours east of Johannesburg in a
vehicle hour hours so if you fly not
very far so the greater Kruger National
Park
okay so just having a look some tracks
of some Impala have been running over
here and I'll just show you back there
it's possible that they've been fighting
no there we go you can see these tracks
over here of a male Impala very dug in
in the ground it looks like there are
probably either running or there's a
little bit of fighting going on between
two males but anyway from our very nice
Impala tracks in the sand let's go over
to Kali who's found a much bigger
antelope
good afternoon and welcome again to
Sunset Safari we are here with this
beautiful water box you can see the mail
they find and the youngsters all over
the place we have the female youngsters
and the male youngsters my name is Ollie
and joining me behind the camera is
uncle James we are in cheetor that's
cheated them right here so for any
questions or comments you can catch us
on hashtag Safari on Twitter or YouTube
chat stream what's happening here it's
so amazing because we have these little
ones right here sitting and chilling and
you can see they're chewing their cud
and this one's here the females see they
don't have horns
oh they have fighting on top of Uncle
Jeb's look there okay oh that male is
chasing that female I'm sure he wants to
mate and that one that female they're
still young I'm sure he's trying to tell
him to tell her something about mating
or some door or move away from him so
what's happening here it's so amazing
because we have to mmm adult male water
box and last time I check the water box
they have territories around water hose
and so I think these ones are just
restaurant levels are low that's why
they tolerate each other but sometimes
they can tolerate other males from
different territories when they are here
to drink water or to to to graze around
and they go back to your territories and
you can see this is a full-grown male
touching his his tail they chasing away
their flies & insects it's hot today can
see these young chaps
I in the shade
there's not a lot going on right here so
that's why I will drive to cheat with
them Rosalyn
how far can how fast can the water park
run remember water parks the their peak
you can say animals and they can reach
up to the speed of 60 to 275 km/h they
are not fast as a Thomson's gazelles but
they are quick enough to outrun a
predator you see they are looking in
different directions because they have
to be safe at all times and more
specially next to a dam or waterhole
everyone likes to drink and then they
are looking out for predators and if
there's a spot one they will alum and
they will take off
oh he was shouting at me
Kimberly you want to know how often to
do these guys mate as you can see now we
have a lot of youngsters over here these
youngsters they are more or less the
same age it means they they love mating
only they would made just right at the
beginning of the of the dry season so
that they can they can give birth around
the wet season that's what they normally
do you can see these youngsters these
young Chefs they have their males day
their horns us it just came out not long
ago and it seems like they they they're
staying far apart from each other and if
we can check those are the only young
males and these ones on here the only
females young females so they need to
have some girls chat and some boys chat
so I met cheated em I'll be going to
check what's happening there so for now
let's go to Sydney with the animals that
will love to eat the water book
we are still here enjoying the boomers
who are still now in bed they are not
showing any sign of doing something at
the moment there all we have seen is
them battling with flies as some of them
we can see they've got some small wounds
maybe is as a result of moving in
between the branches when chasing some
prey animals to feed and the Flies are
just everywhere so you can see they are
not enjoying their sleep there is a big
difference between the dry season and
the rainy season rainy season has got
quite a lot of insects active and flies
are some of those
and see that one has got quite a lot of
flies and is the one who's battling the
most even trying to vibrate this scheme
there you can see all the time to chase
those flies but it looks like those
flies are not listening it's more the
Lions they do sometimes secretly a very
distinctive smell
normally after the rain like now we are
here if it rains
any time from now we know that when they
are wet
the smell is going to be different but
this yes the scent is not bad it is
something that we can tolerate it's not
something that is going to is going to
make me leave the sighting because of
any suffocation oh so they do yes
smell bad because of the water so
sometimes yes after feeding on Koreans
remember lions they do eat fresh meat
yes they hunt but sometimes they also
scavenge and they eat Koreans they also
eat rotten meat after feeding on rotten
meat they smell is going to be different
and that is the smell which maybe I can
say it can be very much bad I have
experienced it before not once and not
twice so these animals when a big animal
such as an elephant is dead they can
even go deep in the stomach
safari sorry is quite very difficult for
the wound to get the markets because
these kind of animals they do look after
themselves and every time what makes the
wound to take time to heal is the
following safari sorry when this kind of
animals has got a wound have got to lick
it all the time and when they're licking
it is when they are cleaning it and that
also makes it difficult for the wound to
recover very quickly because they the
tongue of the lion is caused and because
of that when they are leaking they are
checking off the dead tissues and when
the world is trying to recover they can
open it time again and again now you can
see the world day look at those flies
there is quite a lot of flies right on
top there so you can see that that lion
is not even about that anymore because
he has been having that won't for quite
a long time so I have been seeing this
wool since I have arrived here and you
may I think it is an old injury
Becky I'm trying to check here you know
the easiest way for me to recognize the
man Gary boy
is to check the tail I can see I think
that one day since though the one which
is facing the other side the opposite
side that one must be the man Gary male
because the man gained email lost the
tassel of the tail
you know the lions are the only cats
amongst the big amongst the kids who's
got a tassel at the tip of the tail so
the maenge animals as a result of mange
they have lost that tassel let's look at
that so I cannot see that very well but
I can see that the tassel there is not
highly developed so I am suspecting that
that lion we are seeing there with that
a very beautiful tail must be the
mankini as the manga lemurs are also
recovering from mange at the moment they
are getting much better
so mange is not something good to have
because it is a contagious disease which
can is which can get transmitted from
one animal to the other especially when
animals are sharing food together when
animals are sharing the same shelter and
sharing the breath as well so it can
also pose danger so I don't know if
maybe in a very short space we will
start to see some developments on this
one or maybe they will survive it
for the way these lands are sleeping you
can see that they are so confident that
nothing can produce them none of them is
only watch out well that is quite a very
interesting question
what I must tell you now with regards to
that is that to be a Cub whether it's
from a lion or from a leopard it is not
easy it's a very difficult stage of life
these animals will they are like this
now and the ages we are seeing them they
have survived danger when the Lions has
got cups the biggest threat first is the
other male lions from the neighboring
territories to come over trying to take
over the pride or trying to take over
the territory they can in fantasise the
little ones and apart from that the
Lions when they left behind hidin by the
hiding places the wild dogs and other
predators such as hyenas can also kill
them say the competition is too high
Alliance has also got a problem when it
comes to teething during the development
of teeth they do experience severe pains
and some of these animals because of the
severe pains they do lose their lives
something else which can be a stretch is
what is called a failure in fantasise
failure in fantasise is kind of an
infant size which is conducted by the
females themselves when the females has
done a diagnostic assessment and see
that the little one is not going to make
it because of diseases or because of the
bed condition they can be able to kill
their own Cubs themselves
for now let's go to Tony Coley has got
one of the biggest predators Crocky the
croc is his I can say he's joking or
he's swimming around to get fit or to
check what's happening around here so
what's happening here it's this
beautiful croco delicous see here right
over here you can only see the upper
part you can see the spike like things
and these things are so strong you see
the the ice and during this time you can
see the the way that this dam is just
drying slowly and surely and then there
will be hunting for fish I can find fish
in this pen or in this them and they can
stay they store food if they have a big
meal they will store food in their tails
so when the food get lesser and lesser
they will start utilizing the food the
food or the nutrients that they'll find
from the tail I can see right over they
the water is getting shallow and shallow
so crocodiles are known to travel long
distances from a waterhole to a
waterhole when it gets drier they
tolerate each other around the water
holes but when it gets dry and dry
that's where the conflict starts
some itched it's coming up now
and these are the beautiful PS a wrap
house we can find here the second
largest is uh it's a water monitor it's
listen to the sounds of the world from
the he post a war wonk in the birds
they have the spoonbill they have never
had a spoon filled making a call I'd
love to hear a spoonful making a call
I saw something interesting about the
spoon filled yesterday it was hunting
but walking in the water and it was
submerging its head in the water and was
my first time seeing such a behavior so
it was very hungry
I wanted to see through the water we
have our famous spirit oh and the little
ones me
Ravinder you want to know are there any
baby crocs in the Indus River that one
I'm not sure whether they're any
youngsters yeah but sometime last month
I spotted one small croc so I don't know
whether there's still any young ones but
let's hope we will see the youngsters
you know it's so nice to see the
youngsters all the time yeah we have
this beautiful spirit right thing for
retching and around and and fixing the
nest you can see that it is called a red
big Buffalo Weaver they utilize this
nest there if you see this huge nest on
top of a tree or dead tree maybe in
terms of one and understand that is
Network aerials long ones you find the
most most of them they have the this
huge hidden nest and this nest they
belong to the red peak Buffalo Weaver's
and there's a cheetah cheetah reserve
day I'm sure they having an very nice
view yourself a Terrapin so I've seen a
pious Terrapin on my way to cheetah but
I didn't have a nice view they so for
now let's go to Steve he has some fresh
cats tracks welcome back everybody well
we've come around onto Triple M the main
boundary on the western side and well
you can clearly see in the muddy ground
over here
a leopard track is a beautiful beautiful
leopard track and she's so sim tempted
to take a mold of this but the sad part
about this track is is if we go back a
few meters and what's happened over here
is here are the two cubs two tracks of
the Cubs in the mud and they've gone
across and down and West into a loser I
think and if you just scan the
vegetation here BK you'll see how much
rain fell and apparently the Cubs with
mum were just upstream over here so no
doubt with amounts of rain that fell
last night it would have encouraged her
to probably move the Cubs to an area
that was maybe a little bit drier
unfortunately they have now gone
straight across here and seemingly only
Jack's come here just there in the mud
just there and then they follow her
across into air Arthur's I'm just gonna
have one more little look but it deftly
seems as if they have gone directly out
yeah
back into the drainage system just on
the other side of the road which is
sorry about the areally which is out of
our area unfortunately well that's
disappointing but at least we know that
they've crossed but there's always a
good opportunity that she might come
back again in the coming weeks but for
now probably with the rain that fell she
decided to let me move then being in the
dry riverbed when rain falls like that
is um well instinctively most animals
know you gotta get up and go somewhere
where the ground is a bit drier don't
want to drown ok so at least we know
they have crushed again but there's
nothing stopping them from jumping back
in again we're gonna keep our eyes and
ears on the ground for that to happen
but for now unfortunately folks the
hooker gurus have seemingly gone waste
so on we go we're gonna go do a little
bit of a water point Patrol there's a
really nice sort of breeze picks up now
which is cooling things done quite
nicely which I'm quite happy about come
in on our fire break roads they were
riots in the south western corner the
big Junction over here in it gets all
the other properties Becky are you
asking where is Tinggi I have no idea
what in Ghana is I haven't seen him
since last week's Sunday so he we
haven't even heard any reports of him in
the north but the buffer souk landowners
have been pretty short supply they
haven't been many of them around so they
haven't been covering buffle so probably
as much as they'd like to and we also
haven't had the Juma guards in
attendance for a couple of days so I'm
sure he's around somewhere but he's
probably in the north the last we had of
him was tracks going north and he's
probably up there probably on a kilt
sometimes they can be on a kill for a
couple of days and then you don't see
their tracks and if you're not covering
that area well you won't see him come
out we cover our property quite
deliberately every day we really do
drive around and check for tracks but if
a leopard just happens across there on a
little bit of a little bit of a harder
or grassy patch on the road very hard to
see it could be right there on a kill
somewhere nearby just in the north but
we just don't know
anyway we gonna continue on down at this
lovely road which is going to take us
into the hyena den and while we're just
gonna have a pop pop our nose and thence
hear what they're doing because there
seems to be a little bit of sort of
cloud developing down in the south which
is sort of obscuring the Sun which is
keeping us a little bit more cool but
hopefully the Lions will get up shortly
and start moving because well they don't
do too much when it's very hot
we are still here with the lions and
they are still lying down just like a
carpet and I am so fascinated by this
one here look at this freeway lion is
just like down and having his legs on
top of the other and the other one is
not even worried so when these animals
are so lying down close to each other it
helps to insulate them when is too cold
but now it's very hot and look at that
one is doing so this is a sign in that
animals such as lions they have got a
very strong social bonds apart from that
one is even another one there is also
doing more or less the same I'm going to
show you now look at that so you can see
that these animals don't have problems
with each other and when they wake up
later on your serum even grooming each
other that is a sign of a good social
structure these animals by licking each
other and cleaning each other or
grooming each other it helps in order to
maintain their relationship
so we have not seen any of the big males
here but yeah obviously that man Guinea
is one of the main Guinea males so this
is showing you that yes the pride of
lions normally the females spend much of
their time just by themselves and the
males can be very much nomads you can
come back here when the female is on
heat
the sub-adults they have got to learn
how to hunt remember a hunting is part
of their survival so these animals when
they are less than a year old it is too
risky and dangerous for the little ones
to accompany the others and participate
on hunting activities but once they
become 16 to 20 month two years in full
is when they start to learn how to be
independent so they learn how to hunt
when they're about 18 years so that is
when they can be able to do hunt in full
by themselves but when they are younger
than that the chances of them to take
down something is very much low and
again they can spoil the chances of the
well-experienced Lions here to take down
a prey
I I didn't get that a question very well
if he can repeat that look at that that
is the poor that is what we see on the
ground when we are checking this is what
we look for you can see the three loops
there nicely
this is confirming this is a catch as
the dog has got two loops and the cat
has got three loaves look at those
beautiful Tuesday and they have got some
closure which is right here
after these toes which helps them when
they are feeding may see unfortunately
here by the Lions when they are sleeping
they are all lied down so lions don't
worry too much about the other animals
coming to protect them they have got
good sense of smell and good hearing
ability so when they're lying down like
this you must know they don't have any
of them who is only watch out or only
look out but when they've gotta kill is
where they must have to guard against
the kill the behavior is different when
they have got a kill from when they just
hide when they're just lying down relax
like we are we are seeing now
so now let's cross over to my other
friend
this guy is looking afraid consider his
eyes are wide open we are so lucky to
see such animals during daytime because
around this time they like to hide and
they create this nest that are called a
form in a thicket they will stay there
until it gets dark so now it's so an
opportunity to come out and feed think
he didn't feel enough last night concede
his nose is getting its information from
from the a
and
see the eye is a huge this man save good
eyesight and they are chewing feeding
thee and remember they can also feed on
their droppings because their digestive
system is not as great as other animals
in the ears are wide open because he
knows that he kills small kids be kids
they might handful for him and I
remember when I was still a boy very
hungry I used to have it a doc and we
used to go out with my friends to to
hunt these things what happened was they
have this survival strategy or strategy
that they they do when it comes to
predation because their most the most
live in pairs we can find them in pairs
we can find them singly but when they
are in pairs and they're being chased by
a dog
one will will stay they in height and
one who take off never the talk we'll go
for that one that took off and when it
gets tired it will go to the very same
spot where the one is hiding then the
one that was hiding it will take off and
this other one will will rest until the
one gets tired and those are the things
you I had to learn while I was still a
boy hunting these things
you can see where he's right now it's
well camouflaged you can say that but
the a period of prey
you can spot it easily
yes so let me leave this guy because
he's not comfortable here let's go to
Steve with the hyena
and welcome back everyone while we've
come down to the hyena den and there was
no one in attendance would be around the
corner and we found one individual I
think it's June in the mud wallows on
the other side of the road but she's got
a bit of a limp to her is she gonna go
to the den site which is exciting is a
little bit of cloud cover as I suggested
before she was in the shade of that tree
in another mud wallow where we often
find Buffalo and she's been very very
she's very saturated but she's not going
straight back to the den so I think
maybe we will follow it because if she
does go to the den sorry she's gone
behind the car how rude she is June we
parked so lovely here so that she would
drive in front of us walk in front of us
and then we could show everybody so June
is the hardest of the ladies to sort of
identify because she doesn't have too
much of a spot captain on the right hand
side the left hand left hand side she
doesn't have much of a spot pattern but
the right hand side as Jamie suggests
you're looking for the word juice that
comes out and well this is now now that
Jamie's explained it to us also well
like that it's impossible not to see but
the other side of her there's nothing
she's good oh oh we just drove through
something that was June June left
something there for us whoo she's crate
to the Dead site which is very positive
because um she'll make a noise and her
little youngsters will probably come say
mama we want to eat we want to suckle
which is very exciting we're just
pulling in now everybody hold on to your
horses Jude please don't drop one of
those again that was really really bad
BK now both sort of caught ourselves
there okay so she's just popping up onto
the den site over here she's gonna go to
the shaded east wing which is the
favorite side when it's nice and warm
and let's see if there's going to be any
babies that are going to come out on
certain as June due to the fact that
she's got the nondescript spots and
she's got two very intact ears
yeah but she looks like she's got a bit
a little bit of a lump everybody got a
bit of a limp enlarged mammary glands
yes
a little bit of a cut on the top of it
right here now so I don't know what's
going on but baby
where your babies are they gonna come
out and suckle everyone's hoping they
will they're looking inside she's not
making any noises I don't for make a
noise when they want their youngsters to
come and suckle and I wonder why she
didn't take her kids to the swimming
pool with her maybe she think she needed
some me time
somehow some Juden time everybody here
they come in this Blanc I think that's
Blanc yeah they can they could help
themselves they're all smelling here
again you're June what did you do
something very smelly about you this
morning
so afternoon okay so it's not Blanc it's
pretties two youngsters that have now
popped out and they are always a lot of
fun they like to smell my shoe and
Trish's shoe I suppose they like to
smell everybody's shoe why are you guys
going to that side of the mound that is
the north wing and that is where it's
normally quite warm
maybe Jun wants a little bit of privacy
oh and here comes a third so did plonk
is definitely among them I've just got
to figure out which one is he he's a
little bit darker than the other two are
found his spot pattern
he's also quite inquisitive
a Fiat folks we are interactive would
love to hear from you hashtag Safari
live or throw them in on the YouTube
chat stream hello you're coming out very
tentatively there little one one of the
adults is back kids can come out and
play
precious very precious okay well here
comes in one of the inquisitive ones all
sorts of smells come in from our vehicle
but for the moment June is the one with
all the smells that they're interested
in everyone's excited to see the clan we
are indeed as well as early in the
afternoon for them to be coming out but
there's a really big system building
sort of in the south over there BK if
you want to just show them that system
building which is obliterated the Sun
look at all of that that's hidden the
Sun from view and has dropped the
temperature dramatically and well we're
going to be watching that too very
closely
Jennifer sizes in I eNOS comes from male
and female generally a male or of a
female is generally a little bit bigger
than a male but especially a matriarchal
female has big up as well due to sort of
testosterone imparted on the Yang stat
while in the womb I think that one is
plunk on the left he's got a few more
dark spots so there is just the sex with
our morphism between hyenas in general
and so generally the females are bigger
than males
but a dominant female is generally even
bigger so then others males are
generally much smaller but these three
look very similar in size at the moments
and there's it's very difficult really
to tell them apart I haven't quite
figured out their spike pattern yet so I
do apologize but I think Blanc is the
darker of the three when it comes to
spots that one's quite pale the one in
the front is also quite pale BK and once
it's in the back looking at us longingly
has got a few darker spots and I thought
that was plunk because I've seen him
suckling and cocci a few times
Debbie I'm not sure if she's been seen I
mean this is the second third time
fourth time that her Cubs have been seen
here at the den but I'm not aware of
where pretties been I haven't heard of
her being seen
Trish never mentioned seeing her the
last time and I think James and Ollie
have had bad luck every time they've
come here Sydney as well
Sydney bein seen them but I think
Sydney's actually even seen them out of
the den yet it's a bit of a hit or miss
when you come down here but I haven't
seen pretty since these youngsters have
been at this den but considering that
her two cabs are here it's very likely
that she is around but she probably just
keeps a very different time to to the
others and we've only seen Corki here a
few times Jun obviously being more sort
of around due to the age of her Cubs but
I'm sure she's fine sure she's fine
she'll materialize at some point you're
looking so sad there how sad it's
looking where's the other very naughty
very sad okay so Jun is gonna come
around again and joined by no doubt her
two little ones that are right oh
they're doing some squid ring let's see
if you can listen I might have to drive
around they are very very keen to get
some milk from her so let's just reverse
around that to IBK just going get it a
nice spot I've never live heard hyenas
doing that squid ring that Jamie spent
so much time with the north clan I
didn't even know it was a word but in
deed squid ring is a word and it's that
high-pitched squealing sound that hyenas
make when they're begging and they're
begging for milk or food for mum Oh June
you've gone right inside the den too
hard your babies from view that's okay
you're still very pretty it's still very
pretty and we can get everybody from
this view apart from the two youngsters
that have told mum mum put your bottom
inside the hole so we can at least a
drink your milk in the shelter of the
den
because it's still hot outside okay so
looking at the spot patterns of them
you'll see the one right up at the top
seems to be the darker of the three in
my opinion and my pin I think that's
plunk I'm sure some of you out there
will be able to correct me if I'm wrong
but we'll have to figure out I'm sure
some of you've got some spot patterns
for them already but he's a little bit
darker the spots and the way all the way
down to to his back in his bottom over
the other two are a little bit more pale
so I think that's him I think that's him
please correct me if I'm wrong everybody
he's coming to investigate do you agree
that they're darker BK looks a bit
darker and he's gonna give pretty I mean
June a little bit of a a facial Lick as
you do he's got these two very nice
blinds coming down his back if you go
back to the one on the left again in
there BK those lines there thank you
Michael
she didn't once got a see there on his
bottom there you go back a little bit
yeah he's got a C on his bottom he's got
very dark lines coming down his back
see those there's almost like a
crocodile eating a ball they like a
v-shape with a big spot in the middle
rod and his bottom is got that very big
dark spot on his back that should make
it quite easy to identify thanks Marco
for confirming that that is plunk who is
going to be right in June's way now he
doesn't get they all want some attention
and now this one here has got two very
nice almost vertical lines on the body
of spots you can see that and well the
other one doesn't have too much to work
with at the moment here we go this is
exactly what I anticipated this is one
of pretties gangsters the first one
always to come and say hello hello
cheeky anyone I can smell my shoe again
do you
I love how inquisitive they are I'm not
scared at all
are you do you just like the sound of my
voice hmm what do you spell on the tire
they probably can't see him now hey try
to identify whether this is a male a
female but very brave very brave aren't
you it's just so precious are you going
under the car now okay now comes the
other one a little bit more you know
egged on by the sibling and to come down
and say hello first a little bit of
pasting on the branch this one's a
little bit bigger
what are you doing so the the one that's
by my foot is a darker in color the one
that you can see in frame it's a bit
paler in color you are very naughty it's
just priceless it's as priceless this
one right over here
black red everything hello
so I think this first one is a female
and the one on the right is a male you
can see there's a size difference
between the two of them can't you the
one on the left but then I'm not 100%
sure I think there have been sexed
before I haven't spent enough time here
to accurately identify the male and
female between them but I do believe one
was male one was female
Charlotte universe thankfully not yet
I was busy sitting at the den the other
day and I was enjoying my dad I was
reading something and suddenly I felt
this warm nose touch my foot and I got a
bit of a bit of a fright I must admit
and then it kept coming back and it was
very interested in my shoe obviously
I've got amazing shoes and they must
have a very interesting smell to them
but thankfully not yet Jamie says
there's also a male hyena that sometimes
will come up and do exactly the same
sort of thing you'll have your foot here
and you'll suddenly feel this wet nose
touch you on the leg and if the eye and
I wanted a bite so it would do some
quite quite a bit of damage but I think
they're more inquisitive than they are
trying to get any food from us they're
just very interested as dogs or hyenas
on dogs but like dogs they like to smell
everything so we've got all sorts of
smells to ourselves our shoes have been
all over the place our legs and our
clothes are will our vehicle being all
over the place and well these youngsters
don't get the luxury of exploring very
far so they are very interested in
absolutely every single smell that they
can grasp with their nose and including
our legs and shoes
I wonder how close they've come to Brent
Leo Smith's shoes though see there's
there's Blanc and I think yeah that's
darker in color it's got that almost
that let's see on his bottom doesn't he
see with a hole in the sea with a spot
in the middle hello you're very cute
where's mum
he's running where mom is he'll play
with a bit of grass while he waits well
very very tactile I mean as they love
touching they love cuddling lap spitting
time with each other it's all about
touching smelling and biting in I in a
world and well as we go on from this day
in sight it seems that huh Holly has
found an animal that likes to use a
similar place for sleeping is someone
with the does shovel likes not animal
that loves to kneel when feeding but
because they erect
oh well yeah how can you say this oh
maybe they they're making fun of it it's
because of the the neck they have they
they have this short neck that doesn't
allow them to to feed for smaller things
for a long time on the ground while
feeding while standing so what's
happening now it's we have this small
family here this is the young one you
can see it has this white like whiskers
which act as a tool that chase away
predators if I can pray that way because
these things they they look as if they
are a
a tusk so a predator will be confused
whether this is a task or this is hey so
that's why they have these things at
this early stage hello
I see then I have a lot of faith and
like other animals that's why they are
sensitive when it's hot they have to
wallow in the mud so they can keep them
their skin safe from sunburn and they
also living in Paris they're foraging
around around this time there will be
going you're heading to to to to home or
they will be feeding not far away from
home so the parent you can see the
toffee and the female because it has two
sets of a while one sets of one set of
what say yes that's a female and the
male will have two sets of what's
and it's so grateful to listen and look
at these creators while feeding must
resolve the youngsters they are more
relaxed you can see their tail you know
a water key fits what relax its tailed
shoot up straight we have been palace
around
and this is the best habitat you can
find these guys because they they prefer
open woodland oh this is what I was
talking about the annealing now if they
get tired they know
what is a war talking my language
cynic
we call it fre chioma if our Riki among
Farooqi means pick and then you're Mongo
it means world so that's what we call
these beautiful war talks in my home
language that's Cinderella
what an amazing question cynic there's a
young study hey you think that one is
the last one up on because it's more
than the other ones or this one is a
male I can see it's a young chap they
can see the two heads between the high
next day I was taking a leap pudy
like over there moving through the
thicket it's so amazing and nice to to
look at the war talks or we have we have
some migration going on there you know
on the front ankle James the Impala
migrating from a block to another block
yes is a male nice huh
they to form they do form this harem
this male sometimes because you know
there are testosterone level stays can
slightly co-op then they will act
territorial and let me move forward and
see what I can find
we I cheat a cheat or our neighbor in
reserve
where we can find good Chava
so I'm driving around maybe I'll be
lucky to get a female leopard truck for
now let's go to Steve with the hyenas
well you're just in time
oh it's over that when hyena was busy
attacking the stick the stick was
formidable okay well it seems like we
got it beaver on again we've moved once
oh yeah I hope you managed to find a
lipid he said that's me it has to be
what pop okay they're coming back again
make up your mind guys where you want to
go come on he said to me watch was my
plan for this afternoon I said what's
your plan he said I want to find a
spotted cat so I said very good you go
find yourself one good luck all he has
had some luck with him in the past and
here we here you go this is odd sorry
but my whole body being in the shot
there but let's come to smell the wheel
because um something I've seen with dogs
before when you park if you drive from
somewhere and someone's got dogs and you
park there in the driveway especially if
it's a guest asks who are backpackers or
something where the cars park the dogs
always go and urinate and defecate
because the wheels of those cars have
come from all over the country all over
the place driven through all sorts of
interesting smells and those animals
feel the need to sort of reaffirm their
scent on top of whatever smell it is
that was left there and I've noticed
that with dogs and eye eaters aren't
dogs although they do have a very well
quite a lot of similarities with regards
to how they behave I'm gonna go around
again cuz it seems like the other
youngsters were out again but they are
playing a game of hide and seek with us
plunk and his cousins there you go
tell me when you're happy BK there we go
okay so Michael Fleetwood sent through a
tweet saying that one of the females or
one of the one of Corky's macaques one
of pretties cubs on her right hand side
has got an ET and a smiley face and it's
it's that one there who is getting all
bitey she's got a if she contained we'll
see
oh now here we go here we go it's all
fun and games not clunkers and I decided
to get involved and this is when I you
Nadine's can be the most fun when they
start chasing each other around the
youngsters popping its head art wants to
be part of the game hey don't go for my
shoe I need to get a little bit of
newspaper so that if it does try to go
for my shoe I can just pop it on the
nose again I came all the way under the
car and suddenly stuck its head right
next to my foot this is the cheekiest of
the two definitely the bravest of the
two and they are we gonna see is that
plonk yes that's block playing with one
of the youngsters it's been very gentle
I must admit when he was the same sort
of age as the little dark once he was
getting bullied around like there was no
one's business and he seems to be quite
gentle with the youngsters I haven't
seen any real negative behavior between
other sort of older Cubs versus the
youngsters and there you saw Jun just
gave them a proper little look like
leave my youngsters alone although it's
possible that all three of these sort of
bigger Cubs have a higher rank and she
does now they get to go and give her a
greeting let me maneuver the car again
so he can get some of this action
sorry folks it's a little bit of a
maneuvering this afternoon
hello Jude what's the matter here we go
there's a nice family photo one two
three four five six hyenas in one shots
nah I don't know what's going on with
June she doesn't look it nobody looks
full but does she looks very very down
she's not very happy I don't know what
happened to her last night she doesn't
seem to have any visible wounds that I
can see certainly Nina let's invite some
more onboard before I get my shoe eaten
over here
good afternoon everybody welcome to Juma
private game reserve in South Africa
where we are with the North clan once
again who are all out on display for us
this afternoon the biggest female there
at the top is called June and she's got
two of the cutest little cups there
little dark one there and there's
another one who's just poking its head
out of the hole behind her those are her
two newest Cubs of the litter and a June
being the lowest-ranking member of the
North another North tenth of the Juma
clan this youngster who is playing
around by her head is indeed the one
who's just walking off to the right
there that is plunk that is the
matriarch son and he holds a higher rank
than she does in this clan don't forget
you can ask any questions and comments
you like by just dropping them in the
chat stream below and it's all happening
all the youngsters out this is very
special very very special indeed I'm not
sure what's going on with June she's
looking a little bit sad today if you
look at her left her right ear there
seems to be some fresh wounds on the
right ear there which she is scratching
it's a place where hyenas often bite
each other is in the ear and one of the
sort of characteristic features she's
had for some time is the fact that she's
had no damage done to her ears and now
seemingly she does but she seems to be
the center of attention for all these
youngsters with her bulging belly she
seems to have eaten its little
youngsters where's you wonder if the
dens are dug by unison well essentially
quite often what happens as a aardvark
has gone into a den site or into a
termite mound like this looking for
termites and then over many many years
lots of mammals namely hyena warthog and
wild dog will actually gain inside and
they all have the ability to dig a fair
amount of it out so as to provide space
inside for the the pups or the Cubs my
bad - to breed or to sort of keep
themselves safe from predators and
there's a harvick tivity this is where
everything goes on all the youngsters
get introduced to hyena society
there's different ranks and standards
within the society and you'd expect the
two smallest and youngest Cubs yet to be
getting beaten around and shown who's
boss because all of the other youngsters
are higher ranking than they are but at
the moment it seems to be nice and
playful
not too much sort of animosity towards
them the two you just saw there and shot
so actually this is sort of the second
in charge of the clans
Cubs they are pretties to a daughter and
son and we haven't seen pretty in some
time but considering that her Cubs are
here and the very good chance she comes
and goes we just don't know when well
this is wonderful to be able to see in
the dates aren't there we go
now we're gonna start seeing some play
there's a lot of roughhousing that goes
on between them Lego pizza you want to
know if the favorite food is fine as
well they are meat eaters and they're
generally are well known as as hunters
so anything between a stand balk were
talked up - Impala and even could
Whoville the beasts are known to be
hunted by hyena but it seems that down
here in the sabi sands that the hyenas
probably do a lot more scavenging than
they're do in other parts of the world
where they'll regularly pick up the
carcasses and steal the carcasses from
leopards and even just pick up the
remains left over by lion which only
don't see the hyenas dominating the
Lions down here although it does happen
from time to time in places like the
Mara the hyenas are extremely good
hunters and they take down quite large
prey as big as even a buffalo but they
open them are a different system a
different behavior and but the behavior
can be universal but it seems to be
quite area specific in the juma clan is
quite small so for them to hunter lodge
and the monster just wouldn't happen
Martin how we determine the position in
the hierarchy is just by watching
essentially you can see June here she's
standing with a head quite down cost
she's not showing any sort of
confrontational or dominance displays
her head is quite low down the tail is
tucked up below her if any of the other
adults came into the scene we'd see how
they behaved with her and it's how they
behave with each other that indicates
exactly what is going on in the
hierarchy so it's not us who determines
it but it is in fact the hyenas
themselves and a lot of its got to do
with aggression and dominance but she
doesn't look very comfortable she looks
in pain I'm not sure I can't see any
visible marks on her body but she
doesn't look very happy she got lots of
bat marks on the back of her ears now
you can actually see it clearly now both
of her ears are very very sore so it's
possible she's had a bit of a a
dominance sort of display with some of
the other females within the clan and
she's feeling a little bit sorry for
herself now she lies down in the grass
there she is
see very full belly though so it's a
very good chance that they were out with
food last night managed to fool their
belly also at the feeding time the
matriarch being the dominant in the
hierarchy will feed first and then it
goes down in pecking order so if you
spend time with them you figure out how
to eventually identify them all by
specific spot pattern and shape of the
ears and specific sort of marks that
stand out on the body you can start
seeing exactly who's who and then
obviously how their behavior on each
other is very important this is Blanc
and this is the matriarch son so by all
means he should be the number one
ranking hanging around here at the
moment and let's see how he wants to
suckle
hyenas do not suckle each other's cubs
these are not his not Jun's Cubs the two
dark ones you saw before for aa but see
how they all dominating her
hello Mina that's a great question
ie neurs have two cubs at a time in a
lifetime it's hard to say I reckon
hyenas start breeding from around the
age of three or females become sort of
breeding ready and independence at the
age of three and they can live up to the
age of between probably twelve and maybe
twenty in the wild or depending on where
they stand in the hierarchy so every two
years or so two-and-a-half years they'll
have Cubs so you can do the math that
probably mmm hard to say
hides itself atop made but five-six
litters perhaps maybe seven at the most
I wouldn't say any more than that but
obviously there are exceptions to the
rule but those two there are hurt first
and you can see it is no I think holding
them back as there's lots of biting and
dominance and Jun has come in to do some
discipline there although she has no
right to discipline the offspring of
who's her betters I kind of think of it
as a royal family you can imagine
someone trying to discipline the Queen's
son the prince it wouldn't happen would
it not without your head being
decapitated from your body so there we
go she's giving a very nice cleaning as
good mothers do after the youngsters
have been suckling for a little bit of
time but everybody we hope you've
enjoyed this short time with us here at
the acts of Juma den if you'd like to
continue watching we will be still alive
on YouTube for another hour and 40
minutes so please feel free to come and
join us then and so on next time have a
beautiful beautiful evening and we'll
see you again a tech goodbye
hello everybody so June is not looking
very happy is she
you're not looking very happy the little
youngsters are looking happy but she is
not she's got a bit of a limp to her
back left leg she's not far at all from
the den we first saw her when she came
out of the muddy wall and I thought
maybe it was to do the fact that she was
sinking into the wallow a little bit but
her head is hanging low her back left is
doesn't look very injured that doesn't
seem to be any injury that I can see on
her back left leg it's very wet from her
being in the mad but she's definitely
favoring herself eight years look like
something's gone on in the night
but we do not know we were not yet what
goes on in the night with hyenas very
hard to say must be a very hard life
being high in it always trying to figure
out where you stand in the system have
it's in compete with her ever presence
of lions
there's always leopards around other
clans as well not only your own
constantly busy there we go that looks
more comfortable now she's pulled her
back legs out there flying very flat
good ears they be cat and then I'm
looking great are they got bite marks
all over on the inside and the outside
that definitely looks like bites so I
think she got a bit of a telling off at
some point maybe she overstepped the
mark full belly
maybe Testaments to the fact that she
ate more than she was supposed to at a
at a kill
Corky most likely telling her who was
boss and now she's looking quite
dejected and sad that's okay just looks
healthy seen I eanes with incredible
injuries big back you still here you
little naughty it keeps popping up from
under the car there's a very nice line
on the left side of the body that kind
of angles and the side as well it's got
that - sort of almost parallel lines on
the one side almost like a Rubens sort
of marking is on the body trying to
attend I think this is a male this one
not 100% sure
well talking about hard life
an animal archaea that seemingly doesn't
have too much of a hard time for most of
the time anyway because they are so big
and ferocious Sydney is still with the
possibly sleeping and kuma pride we are
still a really um kaboom us here they
say Dimension X at the moment and please
don't get surprised I am NOT my I am NOT
alone at the sighting I do have the
other vehicles were enjoying the same
sighting as us this afternoon and these
lions are still very much pretty relaxed
two of them already defecated so they
just walked away a little bit few meters
3 meters and then they defecated so we
had to change the position because this
cat was not very nice their droppings
were smelling very bad day
so I can see that now they are starting
to become active and I saw the Hmong
Guinea a male is fully recovered now I
can see there is no sign of mange
at all if you look at him all their
hairs are back and he is just lying down
here look at that if that is the maenge
in email so if we look at the side of
the bodies and they Mane is also showing
off their little bit and the head is
also fully covered so they don't have
any bear patch on their body at the
moment unless it's on the other side
because I only saw one side when he was
coming to this at but I could also
manage to see that the tassel by the
tail is normal
so you can see that they are all still
laying down very close to each other
the tail is very much important for the
Lions
you must check all these cats the tail
is important for balance especially the
case that climbs trees such as the
leopard but the lion's tails can also
serve as a nonverbal communicator
because this kind of animals can be able
to showcase their internal mode just
from the tail let me give you an example
at home if you have got a domestic dog
and you have visitors who brought
another domestic dog when the visitor
comes to the territorial holder when the
territorial holders growling occur you
will see the visitor putting the tail in
between the hind legs which is the sign
of submission so the tail itself a very
important purpose when it comes to the
non verbal communication so when the
females has good cups they do
communicate from the tail as well
so you can see those two there has got
very nice black tips behind the ears so
this is so amazing look at that look at
those black pages there and one of them
on the right I can see has got a mite
there it doesn't look like a tick from
here when I am so demise they are those
who can transmit diseases such as the
mange as we saw from this mahn Guinea it
is transmitted by the scabies so those
are the tick the demise which can be
giving this kind of animals problems
when it comes to the diseases such as
mange and then this experience hair loss
and each eating too much so imagine if
the animal is experiencing mange by this
time of the year when there is quite a
lot of flies so it means when they are
scratching against the trees and the
ground they get a lot of blood coming
out and which will then attract these
kind of flies to come there so I am very
sure that can be a very difficult
experience
so now and while we are waiting for the
Lions to show us while they are thinking
about to do this afternoon let's go back
to the hyenas
thank you rewrite what she's seeing now
is June trying to make Raj what happened
she was sitting where you last saw it
all huddled up and looking very
uncomfortable and her whiny little
youngster came charging towards the car
and then something happened she got a
fright and turn around to run backwards
and then that at the individual there
that's got its head in the hole came
running up behind and completely took
out the little dark individual and that
caused Jun to jump up offed it obvious
it squealed and made a whole lot of
noise and it caused Jun to discipline
this one very briefly and then to run
off to the dentist see if everything's
okay with her little baby so Francis
from Israel says that there was fights
between hyenas and wild dogs last night
around a quarter well I'm not sure if
the Juma clan goes that far and if it
was wild dog I think there would be a
lot of bites on her bottom and that's
where I you know and wild dog when they
fight they get a lot of injuries on
their bum especially if they get
outnumbered but the bites on it is seem
to be by it's from my anus but I don't
know I didn't see it happen myself but
it's not serious injuries doesn't seem
to be any ripping just a discipline
really but she doesn't look comfortable
at all everybody have a look at her
gingerly she's moving the whole right
side of her body
oh well that was awkward
okay so everybody it just so happens
that FC recorded the tumble so as soon
as we are ready Nina's going to show it
for you and I'll send you across to a
little bit of a recap
let's go back up there BK so everybody
did you see that little replay
thanks for the technology we have web to
capture that stuff I do apologize my
game Java radio is not working so I've
got a handheld but with that technology
we hope to to replay some things quite
quickly for you as it just happened
before you came just so now you're able
to see that the big one it wasn't really
trying to hurt the little one it just
happened one of those things you know
when you get frightened then you turn
around and run the other direction and
see who's saying I'm sorry
you are the play thing today there's
plunk plunk want some milk this is where
Jude should step in and say no that's
not for you I don't care who your mum is
but she's not disciplining him jeez oh
she's having a go not a proper thing
just a bit of body language as he is a
flat his acknowledging that he shouldn't
be doing that but she isn't really
disciplining him if she did I think she
would have some trouble with his mother
you know it's like everybody you can't
discipline someone else's child I think
we should in most cases but it's not
really allowed around the world anymore
very very cool we'll spend this time at
the den site to see all the little
things happening toons youngsters looked
like they wanted to suckle again and
still cook plunk had got involved I'm
sure they will come back shortly
but you see Jun doesn't look very happy
your head is down she's looking up every
now and again almost an anticipation for
someone else to be materializing back
normally they just look very lazy and
lie down
suckle but she's quite vigilant and
quiet alert maybe it's because she's
been thrown in with babysitting duty
Tommy I have no idea about what happens
in Ethiopia but I've no doubt there's
still some very bad practices going on
around the world with regards to animals
and animal cruelty and people that tease
or feed ieaders not ideal you do not
want these animals learning or losing
fear of man excuse me excuse me you do
not want these animals losing fear of
man because if they decide to start
coming into camps and start trying to
get food well there's nothing going to
stop them really and the bite force of I
you know with this causes some serious
damage to an individual's leg neck body
arm whatever they decide to grab so
feeding wild animals and for the most
part I'm highly highly against that
because they learn a manner of getting
food that is not natural to them and
then they start becoming what we now
call problem animals but the problem is
the people who start the practice in the
first place don't feed while animals
everybody they all surviving Archer how
they survive is the way that if an
evolution moves forward and those that
don't manage to survive don't breed
keV there potentially could be Branagh
Hina's there's nothing stopping them
coming in but with the high abundance of
other predators that the Branagh Hina's
are essentially excluded there's been a
competition going for years in the
Kruger Park for someone to get a
photograph of a bra now you know I've
most certainly seen tracks but I've
never actually seen a Branagh unit in
the Kruger they're generally do shy away
from areas of high spots that are you
know density generally occurring is sort
of more arid areas where they've got
much larger ranges we find them when I
ask our west coast in Namibia and find
them in Botswana areas where they can
range much further away then spotted
hyenas can and with his lions and
obviously leopards as well high density
of predators that Branagh ena really
doesn't do very well in that regard so I
hope that answers your question I would
love to show you one they are very very
cool but I've actually feel like they
have been seen recently but I know there
was a competition going for years in the
Kruger but getting one on camera wasn't
me wasn't me okay well looks like June
wants us to go round to the other side
once again which we will gladly do all
the little bundles of joy over there
that's maybe why she's looking so
dejected she's there anyone here to look
after all these naughty things I can't
we gonna stop over here again because
you got a little cuteness over there on
the hall if you got him here we go a
little ball of cuteness right there
it's a sec ute
there's lots of activity going on it's
not as much players I thought they would
be I was much biting and chewing pulling
oh very good so the viewers have seen a
Branagh higher and drive when was that
exactly
not since I've been here I'm not sure I
don't think if it was it starts
something that I heard about but was it
yeah or was it in the Messiah Mara the
Branagh you know a very interesting very
very interesting
someone can hopefully give me some
information about where and when that
was seen Eleanor teeth come up behind me
again 2009 the Branagh he never seen on
Drive so that must have been yep in the
sabi sands they're very very good no
doubt a very rare occurrence very rare
occurrence indeed
I've seen them are a handful of times in
southern Botswana in a reserve called
mesh r2 and I have definitely seen their
tracks in the northern Kruger the back
foot versus the front foot being
extremely small in comparison to that of
a spotted hyena spot Elena tracks the
back foot is smaller but no in yet as
small as that of the Branagh in and
often in the track as well in the front
foot of the Branagh hina
you can actually see some fur because
they've got quite a lot of shaggy fur
under their feet okay well while we pay
attention to these very naughty hyenas
that are very interested in my shoe
Kali is probably off the vehicle trying
to show you a beautiful beautiful flower
look what we have found I found a purple
top plant which is also known as sin
Kalos demon
practices it's very common here and in
Zimbabwe in Zimbabwe and shown on a
college atomic ooh boy that's a nice
name
in Shaughnessy atomic quarry this is a
very good-looking tree and it you're its
most very nice it's most like lavender
I'm not sure whether the flowers Smiddy
but the leaves I smell it me smell it
mmm they are Smitty hmm Jesus I'm sorry
about that
q thank you James do you need some yeah
hmm I think I have to f do you harvest a
few and put it in the vehicle
yeah let me go hit the back here
nice looking flower epitope Gotama guru
yes your honor in Zimbabwe
they call it that packaging and look
what I have here for you
you know what this is
it's very long it starts from here to
here it's about the size of my hand this
is called a cashier
mmm it was also it was once called a
schambach pot but the name change from
Shambo pot to cassia I don't know why
changed her maybe because the schambach
name it doesn't sound right and what it
does is in my culture already for that
it helps with that's too graphic I don't
think I'll tell them but it helps with
manhood like a like a sausage tree fruit
just imagine so I'm a ninja now it's my
sort so why they used to call it a
Shambo parties because it it looks more
like a sham a schambach
you know schambach is to whip whip whip
whip whip that's why it's called
Aschenbach port
and these things we we used to play with
them but you didn't know that they can
help with what but only still voice is
to like make swords out of them anyway
our masks they you know this mask this
cheap must we can find in a in a shop
and you cover face then like paper or
plastic plastic ones then you were like
yeah and they put it right here yes
I'm a ninja now some I'm at KU Chavez
Terry tree I've been seen any fresh
tracks yet hopefully I'll find them and
it's not gonna be an easy task because
you can see the Sun is ready going down
it's cloudy
the lighting is compromised
so while I'm busy looking at kochava
let's go to the hyenas
well thankfully don't injure yourself
now with your newly acquired schambach I
need one of them to keep these
youngsters in line of coming to close
sometimes they are now attacking
everything in sight around the den sides
nothing is safe around I uniden nothing
at all they have made their first kill
over there a couple of sticks had no
chance absolutely no chance and be care
this little gangster is coming very very
close one of the new ones he was inside
the den before or she I can't really
tell and there was some digging going on
there was some fresh earth being pushed
out obviously from the rain it's like
mom why are you so far away why are you
all the way over there
good like eight meters from the hole mom
I've got to get past this weird looking
thing there we go I'm gonna brave it I
don't know it is it like flight distance
you know that can't it make it there's
like something needs to get past here
and once it's passed it'll get to Mum
and everything will be fine
it's not quite sure she's just too far
away from the dead they know that safety
is in the den they know that they need
to be able to run back there it in case
of danger looking very longingly at mum
gone mum come on are you going to be
brave at this table I'm going to be
braver come on my cousins over there
surely I can make it surely I can make
it
a little bit more little one
okay say hello to mama go sad oh come on
oopsie plunk just chased it we're stuck
very nice
trying to venture out of the den
seemingly starts to change the spots
already seems like a lot of the dark
firm around the head area this tides
interchange might be due to just a lot
of licking Janet male hyenas mainly
disperse some of them can stay in the
Claire like a plunk for example
well-heeled inherit his mom's rank in
the clan he might even be able to take
it over from her at some stage but that
means it might limit any mating
opportunities within a clad males that
are normally natal to the clan don't
generally get too many mating
opportunities females preferring males
that have come in from another clan so
quite often what happens at the age of
three or so males within a clan or move
away to go and form or to become parts
of another clan and also to go and
improve their opportunities of mating
but it's not unheard of of them to state
but then they're generally still don't
have any rank if they are quite low
ranking or their mothers are ranked low
ranking and they might not do any mating
at all so choice is really there's that
stick is really wishing it wasn't there
I really wish I didn't grow here it's
thinking
important stages of the iron is
strengthening their teeth very important
stage the teeth that are probably
constantly growing in their mouth like
everyone who does have a dog back home
they loved to to chew things to to
sharpen their teeth get the jaw muscles
working
no chew toys around here only sticks
nothing wrong with the stick though it's
organic plenty of them around
Nancy that's a really good question I'm
not sure I mean initially a mom has to
go in to breed so she digs the initial
hole and then the youngsters once
they're able to sort of see a little bit
are probably able to dig themselves in a
little bit deeper but what really goes
on inside the den is very hard to know
because to be able to view these things
naturally in the wild without
influencing them is almost impossible
without may be setting up some form of
camera but we were just talking about
den sites and we're talking about chew
toys the imagine setting up some some
form of GoPro inside our hyena den I
don't think it would last very long
you'll probably get eaten in a very
short space of time
I did watch a wild dog documentary that
wild earth was involved in and Juma and
well there we go there's gonna be some
some false mating there but of a
dominance thing between siblings and the
wild dog den um had what seemed to be a
GoPro or something inside and was able
to show the mum and all her offspring in
the early stages but it didn't show the
matinee at an older stage so it probably
got to a point where the axes were so
inquisitive they ended up eating it it's
probably one of those things that you'll
have to sacrifice if you want to keep
any form of the camera equipment well
you need to know if you put it inside of
at the inside it's going to get eaten
but I've haven't found anything that
details too much about what goes on
inside there's lots of theories and
ideas people talk about infant aside or
sorry super cider that happens between
offspring in the den where the bigger of
the two offered kill the other it's not
something I've ever seen something
that's spoken about but what goes on
inside the den really really is another
matter obviously it could be quite
intrusive to get inside that's in some
form of of Ronald the rover inside no
doubt if it did get past the line of
defense but definitely get eaten but the
channels and tunnels inside are probably
quite elaborate
the plunk his cousin just came charging
past they've got themselves a stick
which they're now going to compete over
the brand I don't have a number for you
to be honest on how often they change
but I think within the last few months
they've changed probably three times but
what causes them to change a lot of its
got to do with parasites ticks fleas and
the lack a lot of it's also got to do
with the presence of predators maybe
visiting the site causing them to maybe
up and leave we had the Juma den sort of
in but for the Northeast for we are now
and that was there for a few months and
then there vanished and we don't know
where they got where they went to and
there were south of the boundary we
believe and then they disappeared from
me and then we found them here again so
we really don't know I think seasonality
mark play apart life cycles of the
parasites the insects that feed on them
apart and also the presence of other
predators
for example of the dead sites in the
Mara get flooded and inundated with
water which would force them to leave
and to choose a new one if we get a hole
here in the ground for example one of
these large turnout Mountains they could
get inundated with water as well
depending on the amounts of rain that
falls and how it falls a lot of rain
fell last night but doesn't seem to have
affected these guys too much but so that
all play a part
seasonality rain are the Predators
parasite loads I don't think there's any
sort of hard and fast rule the hyena
says okay cool it's been two weeks let's
go that doesn't quite work like that
dude you're looking very very sad with
life
so some of the tweets coming food
mention that there's a video on hookah
Murray wild dogs and I eanes fighting
and potentially on elephant Plains which
is very very interesting indeed very
interesting if you they haven't managed
to in to watch it yet because I am in
quite a low signal area so I can't see
that video yet those of you who've
posted thanks for sharing and
would have of activity we are having
here today this is probably the most
active I've ever experienced too high in
a din I think the cloud cover pulling in
has got a lot to do with that
it'll be nice to see some of the other
adults coming back let me see how unions
acts with him when they do
is just a plethora of smells out yeah
for these individuals I just can't stop
sniffing obviously having an adults
on-site makes it possible for them
without the adult they are always hiding
in the side okay well I'm going to maybe
try reposition it seems like all the
actions happening on that side and while
we do so let's go to see if it Sydney's
left cats could get in your letter
not much has been happening here where
the young comas are resting this
afternoon all we have been hearing is
the elephant's pushing down trees and
trumpeting far away from where we are so
the rumors are still very much relaxed
and only three of them defecated so far
as a result of digesting a lot of maybe
meat or food for the whole day so now
it's time for them to offload so that
when they start entertaining the night
or the nocturnal life they can be very
light and run long distances remember
the energy is needed and they must have
to be light so that if need be they can
chase something they are going to come
across
so this is a strategy it is a strategy
for the Lions in order to manage the
energy this has got something to do with
the management of energy so that they
conserve energy during the daytime in
order to use at night Firefly that is
quite a very lovely question if they
evoke a coalition one of the famous and
beautiful correlations in the area if
they decide to go somewhere else
remember correlations are very much no
magic they just move around trying to
have an opportunity all the time so here
if the Avoca coalition moves the females
here we are seeing possibilities of the
other males to come in and deal with
them are very much hi
yes females as well they do entertain
going out and look for the males
especially if this males are strong and
they are showing good genes and loud
roars I have seen this hip opening let
me share with you as something that I
have shared there's something that I
have seen many years ago when I was
still a head guide by the Moroccan
National Park in South Africa about 280
kilometers away from Johannesburg one
day I was on a guided walk and there was
an introduction of these new males
because we were trying to avoid
inbreeding
so this numerous when they arrived in
the park some of them were very good and
big with a black mane this nice black
good-looking males the Israel started
trespassing and roaring and marking on
top of the other's territory and it
territorial holder was so old and he was
roaring coming we were hearing him and
then we had a sighting of this one male
in charge of three females and the new
arrival came roaring and one of the
males voluntarily one of the females
voluntarily went and Luke who is roaring
went and joined that one and suddenly
they went and this old male decided to
run away
that one was roaring coming it could
hear that yeah it is a danger coming
this one is too big and is gonna destroy
me the torturer holder ran away and the
new male came in a female's entertained
him and welcomed him
so you can see that now they are still
I have heared as something about this
ticks pride but they aware about I am
not too sure but I hear that the east s
takes pride in the area which is one of
the beautiful prize as well but the
chances of seeing the sticks prize are
very much low at the moment so just same
applies to the Tala mati I have last
seen them long time ago so at least the
humans are becoming much more regular
because these are the ones I'm seeing a
lot of times together with their focus
so
James I didn't copy your question very
well but just here do you want to know
something about me and the vehicle
James that is a very important question
when I am in the vehicle all I've got to
do every time is to remain seated if I
stand here now I am going to break the
shape of the vehicle these lines you are
seeing here in front of me when seeing
me in the vehicle as well as sensor they
see us as one object when we stand is
when we are going to break the shape and
they will start to notice and realize
there is a movement so that is why it is
important that we remain seated and we
move very slowly
so you can see that the presence of the
vehicle is not worrying these lines they
are very much relaxed at the moment
Steve you the Alliance how they talk we
do understand some of the things but
some we don't why because of the
following they can make loud rolls and
they can growl those are the kind of
communication we can understand that
when he is growling like when he's doing
that when I'm coming close is saying now
that is enough keep a distance I don't
want you to come closer anymore so then
we can read that but also if you listen
to them when they are roaring we
understand that when roaring they are
trying to advertise themselves in your
territory has got nothing to do with our
presence when we are with them
so apart from growling again when
they're just showing off their front
teeth as we are coming closer we're just
showing off the front teeth and closed
the mouth again we can read that is
talking to me I must have to now stop
and observe
so but at the moment they are all
sleeping so they're not showing any sign
so now while we are waiting for the
Lions to wake up as now I can see that
the Sun is going to set maybe in a very
short while let's go back to the eye
eNOS I'm not going anywhere I will be
here waiting to see what is going to
happen thanks it is hopefully your new
Houma pride gets up pursued and shows
you something because we're having all
the fun here all of the five little
Istvan's are out the two little cuties
are are they I start sense is sort of
changes here on the neck and head area
there's sort of spots it started to
change so what are they about two months
dead I thought maybe I near month in a
bits but see me a bit old that hours
away we didn't see them from the
beginning but they've changed so much in
the last few in the last week already
you see all the hair starting to
disappear around the neck that's where
this first spots or started to come
through on the back of the head they are
getting quite brave this one just here
on the right
and gates up so they start changing
colors about between two months and so
the youngsters that you see now start to
change the spots you can start seeing
them around the head and neck area but
it's only after four months four and a
half months that they start looking like
he's other three little hooligans over
here on the right
remember plunk he was just behind by
half a month and his whole bottom part
of his body was still quite dark
although the top of his body had changed
and within well last time we saw him
should I say when they're at the other
den that's what it looked like and then
out of nowhere three weeks or so month
later he looks just like a little adult
look what face plotted as he ran down
the hill he's trying to say hello to
plunk a face planted himself
it is a hive of activity this after did
appear or getting all of your
screenshots in we are super blessed that
we are able to have all these little
visitors and to watch this intimate
behavior between them all and obviously
as soon as you come back to us they will
decide they want to go back to the other
side now cuz it's always better on the
other side isn't it we're doing it like
a half circle around this Mound and back
again in June is just on the other side
they lined out but they're too
inquisitive to leave us alone for long
they'll be back in a moment I'm sure
that arrays and bushes getting a
hammering once again
probably that's a really good question I
mean I I think it's it's okay I'd really
don't have a number for you or a figure
for you I know a lot of the viewers
watching it probably got a much better
idea of the cenar do I've only been
working here for just over a year but
then and no new ones with us I mean
these are the only hyena Cubs that we
know of over the last five to six months
but then they didn't den on Zuma so it's
hard to say I know that there was d1 and
d2 that were born the year before that
no one knows anything about them where
they're gone but I'm sure some of you
out there have got your statistics for
us and know exactly how many of these
hyenas are surviving I honestly don't
know it's well well beyond what I know
at the moment but I think the survival
rate is is better than that of lions due
to the fact that they've got and the den
site iene is only have two youngsters
lions can have anywhere up to four five
at times really depends on the
individual but lions don't have as much
success we haven't seen them coomer's
doing very well in the last year and
with the last set of cubs are perishing
to white muscle disease and then that
one individual just not making it
through at the end and AM buyers we
believe has probably had at least two
litters already since I've been here
she's a pregnancy game but nothing so
very hard to say what we do know is
we've got five individuals here that are
looking good these two youngsters of of
June are looking very very cute to be
cake much better than my face I'm sure
seems you got cuteness overload there
let's keep it that camera framed and
then shall we so they're looking very
very good early days to say whether
these two will survive but I really
don't have a figure for you with regards
to survival rate obviously having two
hedges the bets against one not making
it I'm a plonk being only one we don't
know if he had a sibling and then the
other two for pretty while doing very
very well they're close to six months
now so in the next two to three months
they're probably be venturing away from
the dead looking for food for themselves
but and we're talking about the absence
or presence of pretty have we seen a
haven't we this is one of the youngsters
here
they're still looking a good condition
which means she's clearly been around to
feed them because hyenas don't humanely
suckle at it will not provide milk for
their sisters offspring not at all so
for them to be looking in as good a
condition as plunk means that pretty
must be visiting the den and providing
them with food this little one can't get
enough of the camera one different
realizes how cute it is
Genet that's a really good question
about rank changing with a new clan well
what would cause a a clan to change and
what would cause them to do that and
maybe a mid sort of ranking female might
move often she might find herself or
take with her some males and most
certainly if a female or two females
moved off then one of them would most
likely through dominance display it
looks painful the dominance display will
then establish who would be the
matriarch so most certainly rank would
probably change but within a clan it can
only change through dominance and it's
not a it's not a common for it to happen
but we don't really see it I haven't
honestly spent enough time sorry that
they're going behind the car everybody
but we are we are free to their
movements yet I haven't really spent
enough time to be able to give you that
sort of information but I mean we we
know quite well that waffles was a low
ranking female as she just decided to
take over one day she was her mum wasn't
all let me put my legs back in because
you want to come and say hello again
don't you it's you again
I'm gonna call you naughty let's not
keep that we'll just ever get a name
soon forget her name very soon but
waffles went and just took over and she
dominated completely going from quite
low ranking ad to to becoming the leader
of the clan up there fraught for
whatever time it was that she was in
charge and but if they do form a new
client there's a very good chance
obviously that those that go off will
then start from the top again probably
one of the reasons for starting a new
clan if that happens I don't know how
often it happens I mean I honestly think
that the world of the hyena is very
understudied in fact I mean in the in
the Mara we've got enormous clans they
are enormous numbering 70 to 100
individuals here five adult females with
males coming in and out we don't even
know there's no in here on the same
level in the Gora Gora crater also
enormous clans of IE nevere so how do
you keep a rank with a hundred animals
in your clan how is that possible
the world of the heininger amazes me
there they are again little rascals the
structure the dynamics the behavior and
they're gonna force me to move again
they're gonna force us to move again be
getting that yeah they kept like don't
move we're coming
sorry about the aerial they're having a
great time with it Juma clan this
afternoon and those two are siblings
plonk is the one playing off in the
background and these two are doing their
own a dominance display right now with
lots of biting tail pulling and they'll
always be in every family a bully or
more dominant than in the other so I'm
quite chuffed now swinging Tom I can
identify these two quite easily some
nice hot peppers coming through and so
you start seeing this sort of behavior
this one here keeps coming up right
underneath my car Sonny look around and
there's his head looking at my leg
here's one with parallel lines on the
body another one it's got a apparently a
smiley face and an et et maybe one on
the left there is an ET and a smiley
face one of the writers got those pretty
much parallel lines and then plunk
interestingly enough I've noticed now
has got two very nice sort of pale spots
on his his hips at the back and when you
see it in a moment you'll notice you'll
see what I mean
it's it's definitely the sibling at the
on the right much bigger than the other
one most likely female and showing him
who's boss
the plug has got these two very nice
sort of white sort of pale patches when
the bones of his hips - blonde patches
Airmech he's gonna come through now
watch him come here he comes straight
across dude but I do look at the patches
on his hips his back hips there and you
see there's a one patch quite easy to
see isn't it he's also got the very dark
sort of coloration but he's trying to
find out why they aren't playing with
him
keep moving away from him you know what
it's like even in a royal family you
don't ever play with the Prince because
lo and behold you go a ninja him then
guys and sulks hormones to Mum and then
mum comes along and disciplines
everybody with beheadings so dot playing
with plonk at all he's soon as he
materializes on the scene they're both
stopped playing and walk away but here
he comes look at those two blonde
patches on his on his back hips very
easy to season it there we go hello
plonk come and say hello to everybody
and show us your wonderful patches on
your bottom okay well very good it seems
like citizens turned his camera from his
lazy lions and he is taking a moment to
watch the sunset what a beautiful sunset
you can see that the Sun is burning in
the middle of those clouds there look at
that colors day a nice reflection of the
sunny day so the Sun is going to lead us
to the beginning of the nocturnal life
soon as the Sun Goes Down the hyenas are
going to start calling the Lions are
going to start roaring and the leopards
are going to start throwing is going to
be lovely here in the wilderness look at
that this is gorgeous
I always tell people the sunset never
gets old and thank you very very much
sensor for such a beautiful short
so you can see that the chances of asked
get some more raise tonight they are
very much hi look at those dark clouds
there so that is where the thunderstorm
was taking place earlier when we started
we could hear it is raining somewhere
not far look at that
so the Sun can be very hot I come from
the equatorial region inventor de Sun
and some of us in the different parts of
Venice
we are so very much darker because of
the Sun and the very same Sun which is
varying as too much to get those kind of
colors does also provide us with vitamin
D giraffe girl I didn't get your
question nicely if you can repeat that I
haven't heared from you for quite a long
time
giraffe girl unfortunately we haven't
had any sewing for quite a long time and
the one who is dominating the most when
it comes to that here in this area it is
the leopard called Tiana here where
these lions are it is in kangana's
territory and when King Ghana is in here
is inside the UN Kuma's territory so in
the bush animals are sharing although
they compete and even kill each other as
a result of different competitions that
they are surviving is about survival of
the fittest
so these predators are surviving by
avoiding each other every day so when
the Lions are starting to do this now
when they're starting to groom each
other and groom themselves it means now
is going to be the time so the wind now
is getting cooler I can feel it
so the possibilities of this pride to
stand and start moving they are very
much high so they are going to start
yearning very shortly here
so the Lions the deform part of what is
called pursuit predation pursuit
predation has got something to do with
the pride hunting together there is a
dependency when they are going for a
hunt and each one of them has got its
own role which is different from the
other and they've got different
positions when they are cornering and
animal they play different positions all
the time and sometimes if they mix the
positions the chances of them to catch a
prey they becomes very much slim because
they are not used to the different
positions here by this pride we have got
those that go and corner the animals and
those that chase and the ones that catch
their prey as well
so while I am still waiting you can hear
that I've been saying these for quite a
long time waiting and waiting about what
is going to happen we are going to Khali
and hear what Tory is having at the
moment
I'm still not lucky yet I came back to
our territory which is Juma from Chitra
then we are with the pide which is
called Audrey then he said he had
Poppins I'm calling on the east side of
the reserve so we on our way to to check
today but he said didn't see any tracks
of a leopard so we will be like you will
see tracks around a
and I will affair we we saw this
beautiful bit which is a a common cuckoo
but it was brown to to Rufus color and
we thought it was a female aalam the
female Rufus New York is my first time
seeing that color is a European cookie
and you know the cuckoo sirens sit still
they fly every time
and the surface is a difficult now it
would be hard to spot the tracks because
you know if it rained last night and
then we have the Sun light the substrate
gets compacted and then you know the
leopards and cats they are this fragile
walkers so it's not easy to spot the
tracks so on the ground so these are the
places where we have to check for for
the tracks all be going out for three
seconds and check whether we find tracks
day nothing only see impalas impalas in
power nothing impalas and a walk nothing
yes maybe we'll be like it before the
end of the show sometimes we get like
heed to that point that these lepers
they show themselves to us after a long
search anchor stiff is lucky with the
hyenas Fortman Sydney from Laramie
course is lucky with their lines not
like yet
and the Fortman means a big guy that's
why I called Sidney hot month because
that's a Dodge of Africans with what is
a big guy
so sometimes you have to rely on luck
because you can see the place is thick
very thick
and the smell they can tell you the
smell of the world
that's red Ravinder Ravinder oh it was
she wants to know what the dressing are
they oh this thing that it's a the check
it's a hi-lift jack it's called a
hi-lift jack Ravinder this what we have
to have all the time because you know
we're in the wild and if we get stuck
all in the mud
then we have to check the using
that thing think we have to paint it
green or camouflaged or the same colors
this vehicle listen today we get this
guy
[Laughter]
sometimes they do this in the naval
tends to open their wings and pins this
is called a red peeled Hondo you can see
the the big the peel is shop and then
the yellow pill hump you have this blunt
[Laughter]
and I don't know whether fewer minute
because this one that's responding on
the right there but they can say because
of this tree
and we find a lot of these guys here
I'll keep quiet and listen to to his
call because it seems like it needs to
be given time to to to talk ice chroming
day so it's easily confused with yellow
peeled Hong Kong the only thing you have
to check is the peak and then we have
the horn pill which is this one the red
pill horn field yellow peeled the
southern ground hornbill and this one
called a tokus nice suta's which is a
gray bundle occurred in the hunt allah
is wearing a nice suit because of its
scientific name they might have a nest
somewhere here
so let's move forward James and see
whether we'll like you with the tracks
nice one
nice call right
I have some technical issues with my
with my combs here I can hear FC but Wow
oh how scenic how big is a hornbill
territory it depends which hornbill
because we have the cross southern Quan
hornbill yellow field Hahnville red pill
han pill and a grey hornbill so we have
this one pill in the camp let me talk
about those ones we have the yellow pill
horn pill in the camp and there are two
of them so their territory is around the
camp they they don't want anyone feel
around it because someone feel they
might come but they will normally chase
them away so I think it can be
determined by the food source or they
get because you if you check a territory
gets more bigger when there's less food
around and then if there's enough food
energy in territory
it will stay smaller that's what but the
actual size of their territory I don't
know
okay I've had that I can go to Steve now
with an update and see what he has was
Thank You Molly well I hope you do
manage to find a lipid we are now
searching for a lip at the den site
something happened like a bell win and
they all went to bed didn't come out
again so we decided well let's go and
see if we can challenge Poli to see who
can find the first spotted cat for the
afternoon
Polly are you ready 3 2 1 go
leopard challenge is on now we're gonna
see who will be the first one to find a
leopard after the rains leopards do come
back or they do stop moving around to D
market in a recent mark their
territories so it's a great time now
that's getting cool like this for a
leopard to be moving around and as all
he was talking about with the horn balls
they don't demarcated cheese the way
leopards do that own scent bark they do
this funny things that ask you to do
that again but just I was gonna touch on
the horn goes a little bit because well
the horn bells in camp can be quite
frustrating because I've got a glass
window and a glass sliding door and
James will probably agree as well the
hornbills they love to come just at that
time when you're having a nap and
they're coming to attack the window with
their beak because they see a horn ball
in the mirror the reflection they attack
it's it is and they've got a very
powerful beacon it's is this knocking
sound and sometimes they fly right into
it to try and shout or fire to ever it
is and sadly at the end of last year I
actually found a hornbill that I think
attacked my car my Murrah on my car the
little sad marine in the breaking his
neck where he said
caught one horn below zero in that case
but they do do it they're very well
known for breaking mirrors gran Wan
balls will attack another horn ball
quite violently they either accepted in
as a a new member of their family or
they attack it and kill it so any sort
of windows low-lying reflexive windows
anywhere in the African bush that the
lodge ground hornbills come here they
will break hey we'll break you've got no
chance they're able to break towards the
shells and on their chance of you not
having a window broken so on balls the
red and the yellow the red we've got
them outside my room at the moment in
the well as much as I love them they're
quite annoying at the moment
they've replaced the woodland the
Kingfisher for their loud noise they
make a lot of noise outside my room as
they compete for food one thing is there
dude you catch lots of the insects that
get attracted by sort of the lights
around our buildings and the kind of
hangout sort of around the building
during the daytime and the hornbills
come and clean them all up which is
great
they sits on a chair side my room and
defecate all over my porch all over my
yoga mat should probably stop leaving it
on the ground I've started rolling it up
and putting it away and up okay well
this is Pangolin Trek
I wonder what Kali is one day he's
searching for Leopard this is a great
road for leopards and the one just above
us is called ingre Alley in great
meaning Leopard alley great when as old
this one takes our straights to Telepan
and the heart of druman the more arti
drainage where we often find lots of
leopards moving up and down so I managed
to get a little bit of signal here a
moment ago and I watched that video
posted by in coral and it definitely was
sort of in the the South West because
when we found shadaloo yesterday morning
all the vehicles we saw on the road were
talking about how wild dogs had treated
leopards they weren't telling us who it
was but Wow
watching there we go there's some
leopard food in the road so watching
those at least two iene is being
assaulted by and probably what was it
look like at least eight dogs but
definitely we're having a hard time my
hyenas weren't backing down but poor old
hooker Marie was sitting in the tree
looking very sad for himself I need to
see that that man turning and looking at
the victim for a change with the scrub
here right yet regarded by the sand as a
very intelligent animal is very wily and
very sort of capable of determining of
figuring out things and quite a term of
endearment towards them they're very
very very smart in the animal kingdom
according to the San variability to
escape predators being one of them
he sits his time of day he knows he's
been spotted satanic there he still just
twitching his nose enormous ears it's
just woken up scrub heads as the name
implies f spent the whole day hidden in
some low scrub hiding away coming out at
night where they will grease often found
on the roads because the roads are open
there's a bit of disturbance around next
to the roads which offer quite nice
grazing and also the path of the road
offers a very nice sort of social area
in an area for them to run on the sounds
of the bush start to change from the
daytime sounds the nighttime sounds this
is probably the time when their darts
that their cubs or the I mean it comes
went into their den because June moved
off and the other hyenas know it to be
seen and they'll be starting their colds
and hopefully the Oklahoman's will be up
soon to show you some action hopefully
they come into Juma and we are now on a
leopard search let's see if Ollie or
myself who will become the champion this
afternoon it's nice to compete sometimes
Ollie city's got no luck it's all about
luck
Laura do you want to know what lumber
went to Chitra I think she may be just
she's gone looking for tndi yeah I
think she decided she's been waiting in
the same area for long enough she wants
to find out where mums gone and she she
ventured all the way down said
whether one evening and then the
following day she came all the way back
again we haven't managed to find her
again since then so maybe she found
Tandy and they've gone back over to
torture it there are landowners and
tortured at the moment so we're not able
to get across there at the moment but
also with it with the Ren now there
should be some new tracks around but
before these rains fell the ground after
a lot of rain has fallen gets very hard
and unfortunately a small Leopard like
that can be very elusive you know if you
don't find a nice sort of soft area
where potential tracks have been put
down and we can just avoid you
completely I mean even if you know is
she is and you try frame up she can be
almost invisible so that is the reality
I'm afraid with these animals so this is
the time of day when we hoping to find
them walking in the road as they start
hunting looking for scrubbers and Dakers
and Impala but the night time starts to
become where there do their thing
it could be lucky
paulla I really don't know what's going
on with Tandy where she's at why she
hasn't come back foot Columba really
hard to say I don't want to to put any
thoughts in anyone's minds but I haven't
seen her in three weeks so I've no idea
no idea what's going on with her she
might just be enjoying herself in the
East she might have found some food and
it's quite happy you know lots have been
part of that side baby she's eaten quite
a few kills getting herself nice and
plump enjoying and not having to share
knowing that Columbus just fine by
herself but I'm sure she'll be back to
say hello again
you know the mothers the mother's
instinct to check on her youngster this
is strong with Tandy she's done very
well I mean how many Cubs has she
successfully reared that we know of I
mean I need myself
I know of kochava Tambe and not salamba
it's probably more that a lot of you
back home even know about a nun that I I
can remember offhand I try and keep my
mind set on to the animals that I've
seen it's hard enough to remember all
the names as is but I know a lot of you
been following the show for a long time
so you'll know exactly how many Cubs
Tandy's head very beautiful Cubs indeed
okay so we're coming around the corner
now this is leopard country leopard
country here we oh sorry there's a hole
in the ground as well okay well let's go
over to Corley and see what he thinks of
the leopard challenge and see exactly
where abouts from Juma he is
uncle Steve the challenge is on oh okay
well here thank you thank you thank you
Steve you know what you need this the
Chinese on thirty minutes left of the
shop and then I'll be the one who finds
Leopard I'm on my way to chipper for
soup damn maybe we'll see something
drinking they they work at maybe giraffe
antelope Scuba Steve well maybe we'll
see Scuba Steve going out so I've
listened and listened to to the sounds
that Aubrey said he had from the puppies
but I was in lucky so I've changed
direction and then I decided to come to
perforce weak area skewer Steve here my
friend
let's check maybe we'll be lucky to spot
something yeah oh hello Steve I hope
we'll be seeing some newborn babies in
the future in this Dam who knows because
you can see it's a male or female and
they probably mating and I wonder what
is going to be the name of Scuba Steve
little one skilled is good Stuart Stuart
Oh a steward Uncle Sam said stood but
we'll see about that
so we have a lot happening here you see
there this is a grey heron one of my
favorite Birds a shape neck they call
them snake hair and sometimes because of
the shape and if you can see the
behavior of this bird it's standing and
that's what the Heron does in most cases
they will stand and under will they will
look for the prey swimming and then they
will don't stab it with their beak just
like the black heron if you have seen a
black heron I'll show it in the book if
who you see a black heron it when it's
hot it will open its wings and stand
still they and then it will make a shade
then the fish a frog for something will
hold it because they love being a shade
so it will grab it from the shade so on
the Left we have the yellow peeled stock
this guy's is forever here these days
yes and he looks dirty today you know
what happened he was while he looking
today man
the pink color it's fading now it simply
means his
slowly getting out of the breeding
season and check the behavior of these
two this one it's submerges its peak in
the water and then while walking that's
how they hunt so while walking they
disturb the prey do you see that let's
see and let's hope it will catch
something that would be amazing and
these guys Micron's and if they like
they can stay here all year round
depends whether they have enough food
but if they feel like migrating they can
and they can see the shape be
us it was Steve blowing
his nose thing I'm just checking what's
happening around maybe I'll see
something but it's getting dark now
nothing so I wonder with uncle Steve now
I'm at baffle sook I'm sure he can he
can kept that in his homes that I'm in
Paris who could slowly and then
thoroughly searching for for a cat
spotted cat no like yet for this chap
right here slowly make my way to the
place well find a cat
hmm and I love the breeze
hello get a pill stock I wonder how
these thin thin thin legs carry that big
body day
this huge aide James these things this
is a test can see it's my it's part of
my earpiece and this one is part of my
mod pack it is the one is this thing
that makes us to communicate with you
and hear all your questions microphone
and Yap is simpler terms yes
so now I won't be looking on the front
because it's getting dark and I won't
see any tracks
yeah
they go to the middle to the first
quarterly so we'll check from here too
to the outside and see whether a cat
went in or went out what I'd to know
whether and a mall maybe it'll be
difficult Hey
and the birds are making the last
columns of the day preparing to slip
yes I'm not lucky yet it's I'm sure
uncle Steve have something but let's go
to Sydney with the lines
probably a snake
sorry about that everybody not sure
what's happened on the other side but
you're with us still no Leopard though
it's just go have a look at whatever we
had a a red back strike shouting over
here trying to ascertain where the red
back that's if you can hear it
quite often those sounds will be its
alarm call from the Shrike client
indicate maybe there was a mongoose baby
there's a snake I can't see it maybe
it's down
hidden in the long grass well let me
move on from that sometimes you can be
alerted to leopard 2 by a bird shouting
by a bird shouting but not that time
liver it was too small to spot spot
light as you can see his art the lights
are on let's get our lights going this
is how we gonna find a leopard all
furnaces burning
who are we going to see if we find a
leopard we're looking in an area where
Columbus spends a lot of time I haven't
seen her now we haven't seen her for a
few days and as she moved south as we
discussed it but then came back in again
where she is now we have no idea I've
been checking the usual haunts but this
is all scenario that's quite regularly
frequented by sandy who we haven't seen
as well I said for quite some time
ODOT they are around somewhere everybody
and they will turn up just in time
they're having a little bit of a holiday
you see there no we don't have a TV show
for some time sir okay cool
we'll just uh go away for a few days
just take a few a couple of weeks off
it's in there right isn't it their film
stars after all a couple weeks a year
can't complain about that Kenna me nah
Philip Yordan if my car breaks will I
fix it well it really depends what
breaks we do have a mechanic that is on
site he's not permanently working for us
but he is a magician his name is opa
which is quite interesting because opa
in Afrikaans means grandfather and I
think he's about the same age as me
maybe even younger than me I don't think
opai's older than me that's for sure so
a young gentleman of course but he's a
magician we will struggle with things
and then he'll arrive and within five
minutes he's fixed the problem that's
what you get experience in certain
things knowing exactly what to do but
though he generally fixes most of the
mechanical issues but when it comes to
basic stuff most certainly I'll sort
that out we just got a new ala hiding in
the bushes there so for those of you who
new to Safari the spotlight is arts at
the objective of the spotlight as it
reflects the eyes back from animals
animals have got this filament or lens
on the back of the iris called the v'
it's a pizza lucidum which is designed
to absorb as much light in the
atmosphere as possible to allow animals
to see when it's dark not all animals
have it we don't runners don't and apes
elephants have a very minor one you
don't really see the reflection but when
you shine it on eyes they shine back at
you and that's how we spot them
so we're looking for the eyes shining
back and then when we spot them then
often you can know whether it's a
leopard or something but there's quite a
bit of discussion about it takes a lot
of time to to get your head around what
exactly what animal it is
Nina I'm hearing most of it from Sammy
but I'm not getting the question at all
not getting at all Sam you saying
something about someone roaming but I
don't I'm not hearing the rest of what
you're saying to me I'm afraid
sorry about that Sam you I'll try and
get your question through and answered
for you Sam you you want to know about
gorillas well it's very hard to say but
um gorillas occur in forested areas very
dense forested areas we don't have any
of them down here but may be very long
time ago these areas used to be more
forested and then it is possible yes the
gorillas were around but I'm not sure if
it was ever this far south we still have
gorillas in sort of the north in a sort
of Central Africa but none right now at
the moment so gorillas are more of a
forest animal not an open savanna
specialist mu so baboons are probably
the closest relative with us of course
to the Apes of the jungle I hope that
answers your question for you and what
wonderful to see gorillas wouldn't it
it's one of my bucket lists to go up and
see them but they enjoy very green wit
forested areas down here it's way too
hot for them it's you dry I think it
gets quite hot where there are but it's
very humid that's where they enjoy it in
the tropics
in the jungle a proper forest the jungle
of Central Africa
so when the Savannah formed ourselves
and baboons are probably the first sort
of creatures to or of that sort of
family to have roamed out of the forest
and we moved away from our dependence
seat with trees gorillas obviously don't
spend too much time in trees they're
very big but they do spend it's tall in
the forest they haven't invaded or moved
out of the forest and that's where they
spend their time okay well we've come
towards Juma watching halt pan hoping to
find something nothing at the moment
this is another last-ditch effort to see
if we can find you a spotted cat we're
gonna go back towards chela Padma then
cut easy West's time maybe you want to
see a bush a bush baby a bush baby would
make up for no leopard well I will try
and find you a bush baby along this
river an area just thought I left is an
area where we often find them but there
I haven't seen one in some time I don't
know what they've been up to it might
just be the fact that the trees are so
dense and we just don't see them moving
around as we do as much in the winter
months we see them much more clearly
because our spotlight shines so much
further in and I was talking about I
shine before bush babies have got some
of the brightest eyes Archer because
they've got such big eyes and while they
reflect back beautifully and they've got
very big eyes a very big orangey red
shine that comes back and they're what
are the easiest animals to know
immediately what it is because well
they're in the tree and then they study
bumps and you see them fly like three
four meters away so they're quite easy
and them also identify but when you
start driving around and you you see a
dega or a Steinbach the size of them and
the color of their eyes could quite
easily confuse you for a leopard they
often do takes a lot of time and a bit
of practice to get that done
because we just not designed to see at
night that's why we invented these
wonderful torches
Caty well lepers aren't essentially
going to be attacking us if they were
with this industry just wouldn't work
you know we're not walking at night
leopards at night on foot probably run
away from you anyway but essentially
wild leopards have a fear of man wild
lions wild all the wild animals have a
fear of man because we evolved on this
savanna landscape with them so if they
do if the only time you actually need to
be afraid of a leopard or worried about
it but if it's a sick or injured and
then you need to be very careful and
it's body language will tell you
straight away what's going on you'll
hear it you'll hear it but it was really
if a leopard wants you to jump in this
car and pull me out there's really
nothing I could do about it absolutely
nothing but while leopards essentially a
pretty docile and pretty relaxed to the
vehicles once their obituaries
they're not out to get us we're not on
their list of food items and we don't
walking around at night because if we
walk around that well that's just gonna
put us in the time of day when predators
are active well talking about nighttime
predators and searching awliyas still on
the search for leopard whereabouts is
exactly I'm not sure but let's go see if
he's had any luck gave up looking for
tracks but I'm using my spotlight to
look and search for for the flesh
and then uncle Steve what I'd love to
see and what's in my bucket list is to
see his go and see they're all wrong
with hens in the wild I would love to
see that I've never seen a Ranga tent
before like only saw it on TV screen so
I'm not far away from from the camp
because I made a big loop to see whether
all detects something or see something
or smell something so all the way to
where Taylor am day oh wow I wanted to
chalk check whether we'll hear the frogs
calling love the frogs I love them a lot
so we were on IR now you can see we on
black and white yes because we have to
see within these thick bushes and this
darkness you can see the clouds all over
the sky and what I want to do there is
to switch off my car
early belly can I make a leopard call
let me try it I can't because we have
the contact call you remember we have a
turret Rolla : oh that's the territorial
call and then we we have this one that's
when a female is calling for for a cop
so what I want us to do is I would love
us to to switch off the lights even the
the the presenter light and we go with
IR yes this is beautiful sort of for the
lights and I just want you all the
viewer to to to to to to to close their
eyes and listen to the sounds of the
world these folks around here and tell
me what you are feeling I want you to
imagine that you are just at the back of
the vehicle now so if I also love to you
the FC to think away if they need to
that I would like to have him a minute
or minute and a half to click right in
this little occult
[Laughter]
open it believe everyone felt as if he
was just right here in South Africa
freakin National Park wasabi sex
yeah I feel like I can I can spend more
time here listen to me to the coins
because I wrapped them and I hope
everyone felt the same this is magic
what must I do
must I leave yes
oh these are the things this is that the
things that they make me feel more
touched to the wildlife listening to the
calls of the frogs the birds
yeah this is magic and it gets emotional
sometimes did you feel that
but I've also felt emotional
Mike want to know this Fox they call all
year round remember Mike the frocks they
are most active during the wet season
during that the dry season hope a day
they hibernate I can say that but they
can stay in a place for a while and a
long time on underneath the ground they
will hide themselves there in a place in
a suitable place and then they'll only
come out after the rains or during the
rainy season so they they don't call all
year round that happens during the wet
season
fresh droppings of elephant can smell
them also good
Oh fortunately I didn't find it in
leopard but I've enjoyed the frocks but
for now let's go to uncle Steve and see
what
world Kali it's not over yet bye friend
do we still have two minutes or so to
find a leopard and that everyone out
there knows I think there's even a
hashtag for last minute leopards if
there isn't there should be but we
unfortunate having difficulty with our
infrared lights so that's why you're
seeing I am still possibly I might not
be in color depends on what forces have
been to put on from the other side of it
we don't have a working IR light I don't
know why and is well beyond my capacity
to explain but because tried everything
you can but for now we are just going to
drive along and see what we can find
last couple of minutes on the show I'm
just gonna take a left yep go around
quarantine maybe we'll get someone
moving around in the darkness
who knows there's been a very nice
afternoon I'm glad that the clouds have
moved and it doesn't look like there's
any looming rain right now it might rain
at 2:00 2:30 again in the morning
throwing us all into a flurry or should
I say James and Sir flurry as he ran to
cover all the vehicles we really did
come down last night the rain well the
Lightning was right on top of our heads
incredible if you like laughing if you
don't I think it would have been
terrifying
I was quite terrified for a moment said
he had a bit of a fright as well he was
in the bathroom at the time when it
happens
can you imagine nice had to go on some
leave to recover from the trauma from
standing in the bathroom while I think
arraigned around his head
well it has been a wonderful afternoon
with the Juma clan and we have
thoroughly enjoyed it ourselves because
I think I've been very lucky we spotted
Jun just at the end otherwise we would
have left the do - Jun Clare other to
McLeod altogether but we managed to
follow her back and what a marvelous
afternoon we had indeed and well James
has had a good afternoon out there with
collie Sydney with his very flat cats
sadly we've lost signal with him but
thank you to all of you for joining us
for another sunset Safari we'll see you
again tomorrow morning and I brought
nearly for another sunrise Safari come
as you live from Juma and the Mara for
myself for the race the team thank you
for your questions comments with you
tomorrow good night
[Music]